[Music]
I'm grateful for my wife Josh Duggar's
wife Anna is also giving thanks as she
reflects on the past decade loyalty is
one of those fundamental foundational
keys in marriage despite her husband's
shocking scandals back in 2015 the
Duggars have moved forward and are
celebrating their family milestones on
Thursday Anna shared a series of sweet
Instagram photos of her kids including a
snap of Josh kissing her forehead
writing in part quote June was an
exciting month for our family Josh and I
celebrated our 10-year engagement
anniversary the mom of five added the
past ten years have been a wonderful
adventure so thankful for God's
redeeming Grace and his blessings to us
along the way especially our five in
this comes two years post rehab and
three years since Josh confessed to
multiple acts of sexual molestation in
March 2016 Jim Bob and Michelle Duggar
eldest son left a faith-based treatment
center after confessing he cheated on
his wife and had a secret addiction to
internet porn well it's nice to see the
former reality star seemingly turning
his life around